dans le chat quand même on est en live
pour parler du thunder c'est le début de
nos très grave talks on va en faire 1 8
les huit premiers choix et bien c'est un
hasard du calendrier mais ça tombe très
bien puisqu'ils sont montés le soir de
la loterie le on commence avec oklahoma
city et donc et pour parler de cette
draft rendu du thunder nous avons on va
faire comme ça ça va être le dispositif
pour chaque pour chaque émission pour
chaque pré draft text représentants à
dire des fans un représentant des médias
et un représentant de envergure histoire
d'avoir différents sons de cloches
différentes impressions et des
complémentarités
côté médias josh moisan du nba corner
pod comment tu vas va très très bien
ravi d'être ici très honoré d'être
invité par envergure où la tension qui
nous a invité plusieurs fois déjà dont
il n'était il était quand même logique
de rendre la pareille
pour représenter les fans on avait
beaucoup beaucoup de choix parce que
mine de rien c'est une équipe qui je
pense grâce à son succès
passé un temps pour être gentil beaucoup
de fans mais c'est constant qui en plus
al'avantage déjà s'être intéressé aux
prospère d'un peu près donc c'est
constant qui représente le comte we are
thunder france mais on attend également
un attend également les autres dans le
chatt celle constants salut bonsoir a
tous très heureux d'avoir été invité
effectivement des comptes louise wilson
d'air france ou thunder franchi en
acompte pulpe et pendant pas mal
d'années là bizarrement ces derniers
temps il y en à moi
rebrab pourquoi mais l'entrée heureux
d'être ici pour parler de ce pic deux
annonces à six ou sept way est content
de monter en 2 c'était une belle
surprise pour toi pour commencer la
séance très heureux d'être ici pour
parler oui c'était une énorme surprise
énorme surprise personne ne s'y
attendait dans la commune ce qui s'était
passé l'année dernière vous avez bien
refroidi là on passe de 4 à 2
il espérait
et puis et bien pour parler pour parler
prospects notre notre talent local
alan riou qui d'ici qui a un match de
playoffs ensuite avec sa franchise de
boston qui charge est
chargé en émotion très doit tous très
contents des fois
on salue évidemment ceux qui sont déjà
arrivés dans le chat y en a plusieurs
salut tout le monde on espère que vous
êtes prêt pouvait déjà envoyer vos
questions ça va se faire en plusieurs
parties première partie on va faire un
état des lieux puisque pour généralement
il ya besoin de fixer les équipes qui
seront en haut de la draft donc on va
faire l'état des lieux quelle est
l'identité de l'équipe quel est le
roster comment quelle est la direction
prend que prend cette franchise
ensuite on va comparer ça avec les
différents prospects qui seront
probablement dans leur âge là évidemment
à faire des hypothèses mais
mais bon numéro 2 ça devrait aller en
numéro 10 pour plus de mal et puis et
puis la partie 3 ce sera la foire aux
questions puisque j'imagine qu'il y en
aura plein surtout que ok si à des pics
encore l'année prochaine l'année d'après
son plein de nous pique tous tentent
donc on recommence
c'est une équipe à pic on commence on
commence avec le constat l'état des
lieux où on est ok si quelles sont les
perspectives pour l'année à venir
déjà est ce qu'on peut constant
donner une direction est ce que quand on
est fan on est là on arrive à voir
quelle quelle est la direction que prend
cette franchise est ce que c'est clair
pourquoi
pas pour l'instant
en fait la direction qui a été prise par
le thunder depuis par du coup depuis le
part de chris paul et la reconstruction
complète a été entamée c'est on accumule
il ya plusieurs paris qui ont été faits
et la tuque et essayer de voir
effectivement une sorte de discours dans
et la volonté de sam presti de sortir un
petit peu des cadres n 6 de melay
notamment avec la drave de poussettes
ski avec la draft avec la barbe de theo
naïve en sortir des cursus
universitaires classiques pour aller
prendre d'autres joueurs qui évoluent
dans d'autres championnats qui peuvent
apporter d'autres choses après en terme
de
juste d'autres jeux là effectivement on
voit qu'il ya quelque chose qui se qui
se met en place notamment avec l'arrivée
de marc del haute
vous dire offensif qui est très
analytique constant je te coupe je te
crois sarr grésille problèmes qu'on
avait eue en avant on va essayer de
régler ça je te redonne la parole après
sur ce que tu étais en train de dire je
donne la parole à josh
sur ce que tu vois cette année
quelle quelle identité tu donnerais au
thunder
sans rentrer dans le jeu précis on ira
après sur la tactique mais vraiment
c'est aussi important c'est ça veut dire
c'est quoi en fait l'identité oklahoma
city thunder j'ai l'impression
aujourd'hui que effectivement comme
disait constants elles étaient 2020 ça
me presti le general manager a lancé une
opération de reconstruction totale et
quand je dis total c'est vraiment il a
poussé le cursus dire ce qu'il est en
train de faire c'est du jamais vu
auparavant dans de quasiment dans
l'histoire de la nba
récolté autant de pile de draps fois
qu'il en a 38 là jusqu'en la draf 2028
quelque chose comme ça c'est un nombre
impressionnant on a du mal à faire sens
de ce truc là en tout cas moi j'ai du
mal à faire sans j'ai du mal à des fois
à savoir où il veut aller exactement
maintenant si on regarde c'est un peu
plus calmement on se rend compte que il
a il a quelquefois il ay un joueur qui
est clair pour moi c'est shaded view
c'est alexander et j'ai l'impression
qu'il essaie aujourd'hui de construire
autour il y fait des tentatives ils ont
ils essayent de choper des talents pour
bien entourer shaggy jesse alexander et
c'est très intéressant au final parce
que on dit et il l'a dit ça dans sa
conférence de presse de fin de saison
qu'il ne souhaitait pas être pressé par
le temps qu'ils ont le temps encore
aujourd'hui veulent se donner le temps
de construire ce club cette identité
puis d'identité elle est déjà là je veux
dire sam presti aux commandes depuis
longtemps maintenant
ça va être intéressant de voir en
combien de temps ça va se passer tout ça
parce que on à la draft là mais je pense
que d'ici deux trois ans il va falloir
commencer pour sam presti a déterminé
quelque chose où ils veulent aller
qu'est ce qu'ils veulent faire avec qui
veulent le faire surtout
c'est intéressant parce que c'est aussi
une des questions qui va se poser ce
qu'on cherche tout de suite à avoir des
joueurs
disons d'impact court terme ou est ce
que on continue encore ce projet de
construction et on va aller espérer des
optiques à la drave déjà 2023 qui
s'annonce plus dans sur le haut à l'âne
juste un mot là-dessus si on doit
comparer les deux draft même si
évidemment il reste encore un an avant
la 2023 la 2022 pour plein de raisons
notamment qu vite et c est peut-être un
peu moins prête que celles qui n'y ait
même au niveau talent du sel de l'année
prochaine ouais la draft 2022 sarov la
plus simple empaqueter négativement par
le critt parce que c'est la draft où les
derniers de la saison junior de la
saison senior de lycées ou a été
quasiment blanche à cause de la pandémie
et c'est des années extrêmement
importante dans le développement des
gros freshman donc ça va d'ailleurs
forcé des joueurs à sauter le pas cette
draft john hocking a aurait dû est un
top 5 de cette draft il était prévu il a
préféré aller dans la draft avant ça
mais en même temps sa draft 06 shannon
sharpe donc c'est un peu ça va un peu
dans les deux sens mais ça les gens
s'ouvrent aime souvent dira dans un an
ça va être beaucoup mieux alors que et
on souvent mettant peu à mal la draft
actuelle on en parle et vous dis toi et
moi sur la 2020 où les gens ils disaient
qu'ils étaient nuls en deux ans après je
pense qu'on était gens ont été très durs
avec cette draft là
mais
2023 honnêtement bon bah déjà il ya
quelqu'un en france qui est un aspect
type générationnel on n'a jamais vu
dès que je vois jouer en vrai monde ont
fait fait des sensations étranges
et puis une classe incroyable c'est aux
états unis donc on pour ça que je pense
aussi que le but doké ci n'est pas de
gagner des matchs l'année prochaine donc
je pense que c'est pas dans le but de
dalé ans pour eux mêmes ou plein en fait
je crois que pour eux c'est pas ce pas
l'objectif
intéressant sur quel roster on va
compter l'année prochaine constant va re
tester ton sang pour voir si ça va mieux
ajoutant 0 l'attend pas du tout constant
mais en attendant ce que je peux faire
ce que je suis en capacité de faire
c'est vous m'entendez la argh oui on
tente en face à grisy est-ce que ça
grésille non ça ne dis pas tu peux pas y
aller par mois du roster vas-y oui voilà
le roster est globalement un joyeux
bazar soit positif quand même planète a
été un peu négatif donc grand tu veux
pas être négatif quand tu vois la saison
quand vous voyez le thunder cette saison
c'est pas possible non le roster
globalement il ya
trois joueurs compétents dans l'effectif
non il ya bien évidemment des deux
intouchables à savoir jeudi guy dit chez
guillou seither qui sont globalement le
centre de thar en construction c'est le
projet pour le futur
évidemment le guen sorte qui soulève
quelques interrogations parce que ils
arrivent en dernière année de contrat il
va y avoir un petit peu de de
discussions autour d'une éventuelle
prolongation il ya darius belle idée qui
rentre dans cette même catégorie qui
arrivent en dernière année sinon le
reste vu qu'on grave que des jeunes tout
est sous contrat rookie fait du très mal
c'est sous contrat ou qui dut jeremiah
robin se placer sous contrat rookie même
la joie le catastrophique tiger woods
c'est sous contrat rookie
beaucoup c'est sous contrat rookie et
donc voilà ta pas non plus tu as derrick
favors tu étais à l'été trois vétérans
entre guillemets c'est ken read williams
qui arrivent en dernière année de
contrat qui est payé une broutille
globalement pour ce qu'il apporte
tamek muscat là qui est énormément
apprécié ce soit par la fanbase du
thunder ou par l'organisation parce que
c'est quelqu'un c'est un vétéran qui
m'ont toujours les dix ans qui vient
jamais nous qui vivons additionner les
chaînes pour mike oui
il faut l'activer sur certains états
derrick favors qui bizarrement appris ça
plaira option' à 10 millions on se
demande bien pourquoi
lui je ne sais pas s'il sera présent
dans l'effectif d'ici le premier match
de la saison régulière 2022 2023 mais
pour l'instant il est encore là donc on
va comptabiliser parmi l'effectif mais
il est vraiment en boubou de rotation et
sinon vite tout le reste c'est du jeune
et là vous voyez les 27 millions donnés
à kemba walker
il faut un peu mal mais au fond ils sont
là bas
c'est un peu cher quoi
on va on va rentrer on pas rentrer donc
la stratégie des décideurs il ya
beaucoup de pick sur les années à venir
alan disait c'est pas leur stratégie de
gagner josh est ce que tu es d'accord
avec sakho constant je te voyais tu
disais oui la dernière fois que je t'ai
parlé d'été pas sur 10 elle va falloir
commencer à voir des résultats peut-être
parce que les fans s'impatientent le
process
conviendra à la fin de sa patiente mais
sam presti ans dans sa conférence de
presse de fin de saison régulière l'a
dit très clairement l'objectif c'est
2023 il n'y a pas d'objectif de résultat
en fait il a dit en conférence de presse
si je voulais faire une saison l'année
prochaine à 45 oui je pourrais le faire
parce qu'on soit il et les assets la
lépi de draft il a des contrats qui peut
facilement bouger mais lui c'est parce
qu'ils recherchent ce qu'ils recherchent
c'est une équipe capable de jouer le
titre pendant plusieurs années
consécutives et pas de se retrouver
enfermé en milieu rôle milieu de tableau
à sortir au premier tour mme finale de
conférence pour certains ils peuvent
considérer que c'est un peu extrême
comme les autres en
moi je n'étais pas loin de penser la
même chose mais finalement la finalité
en nba c'est quoi c'est de partir au
premier tour ou d'essayer de gagner des
titres pour moi c est gay si ça passe
par deux ou trois saisons globalement
c'est pas assez pas très excitant à voir
jouer mais par contre ensuite tu fais
pas ce qu'a fait le thunder pendant
quasiment dix ans et demi finale de
confine à lise kung fu finaliste nba moi
je suis prêt à encaisser cette
reconstruction et avoir une saison
supplémentaire ou
t'as pas forcément les résultats qui
vont avec
j'entends pas évidemment évidemment le
bout de vingt minutes dans le chat on se
demande si
jal va pas chez va pas être sous les
plus que les fans finalement puisque
c'est lui qui est important de réagir
là-dessus et je trouve que notre chat tu
as tout à fait raison c'est exactement
ce que j'allais dire il ya un moment
tchéquie james alexander tu vas finir il
va finir par être complètement
tu vas aliéné aline est ton meilleur
joueur si tu continues sur cette
stratégie je pense que il
serait important de préciser que l'année
2000 23
ça correspond à la construction actuelle
engagé par sam presti c'est aussi
potentiellement le moment où va y avoir
un nouveau nouvelle convention
collective en nba
c'est parce que logiquement le cot le
deal actuel court jusqu'en 2023 enfin il
censé se terminer à la fin de la saison
2011 3 2024 mais ils ont le syndicat des
joueurs et les propriétaires ont une
option de sortir de tout ça en 2023
pourquoi c'est important parce que ça va
redistribuer toutes les cartes notamment
les cartes financières de comment tu
j'attends salary cap comment tu
distribues ton argent et ça d'un point
de vue stratégique en tuiles le thunder
et que tu es dans une logique de signer
des contrats et d'essayer de vivre ça
à la fois sur le court sur le moyen et
sur le long terme c'est vraiment de la
et s'y tiennent ils tiennent une
comptabilité de dingue
c'est très important en fait comme
données donc il ya aussi donc la
stratégie de reconstruction avec les
pics de draft comment tu les utiliser
tout ça mais il ya aussi il faut pas
oublier je pense de pointer du doigt
cette histoire de salary cap et de et de
situation financière qui va je pense que
sam presti envie d'y voir clair parce
qu'ils se sont fait avoir déjà par le
passé par 7 avec une situation comme
celle ci que donc je pense qu'il n'a pas
envie que ça recommence quoi mais pour
bien sûr mais à regarder et ça ça va
être une grande discussion parce qu'on a
vu bensimon et on en a vu d'autres
joueurs sheth il en a marre parce que on
en a entendu loup d'or dire j'ai envie
d'aller en playoffs chase jesse
alexander il a déjà goûté aux playoffs
il a peut-être envie d'y retourner mine
de rien il avance en âge donc au bout
d'un moment ces joueurs là ils ont aussi
la pression de l'extérieur ils ont aussi
la pression de leur carrière et ils vont
se dire moi j'ai envie de faire quelque
chose j'ai envie d'être un joueur qui
compte c'est bien de reconstruire mais
au bout de trois quatre ans ça me saoule
quoi et ils auraient tout à fait raison
si je peux me permettre
chez totalement pour l'instant en tout
cas
pour l'instant
pour l'instant quatre anneaux non bien
sûr mais c'est ça oui on a l'impression
c'est ce que je veux ce que je voulais
dire c'est qu'on a l'impression le
thunder haletant et c'est vrai ça à la
fois vrai c'est la fois fou voilà
ça dépend ce qu'on entend par avoir le
temps quoi bon on va voir avec les
prospects dans quelques minutes quelques
est ce qu'ils peuvent apporter ou non en
tout cas
alan quand on pique numéro 2 on attend
de toute façon un joueur qui va apporter
quasi immédiatement au moins un petit
quelque chose ça va pas être la drague
2021 où il ya eu des très bonne saison
rookie surprenant surprenante même mais
mais voilà on attend attend quelqu'un
qui au moins amène ses forces à lui et
va travailler sur d'autres choses - pour
moi dans le top 3
dans une dans les grosses ventes de 5
j'attends des joueurs à très hauts
plafonds bien sûr mais aussi au plancher
c'est à dire des joueurs qui sont qui
vont dès la première et la deuxième
année montrer des flashs de stars les
flashs de potentiel à l'instar de flash
de potentiel olivier pourquoi pas donc 6
essaiera et en même temps qu'ils vont
soir après soir apporter quelque chose à
la hâte on ressort même dans une équipe
qui perd même dans une équipe qui n'est
pas excellemment bien construite cette
pauvre
je pense que c'est quelque chose qui est
souvent un peu mis de côté souvent on
veut beaucoup beaucoup du fit ou alors
on veut beaucoup beaucoup au potentiel
dans le top 3 normalement tu dois
récupérer des joueurs qui doivent allier
les deux c'est donc je pense que dans
cette draft il ya potentiellement trois
quatre joueurs qui peuvent avoir des
flashs pour être de futurs compte dans
cette ligue et qui en même temps dès
l'an prochain
vont montrer des choses et des équipes
sur terrain donc le thunder et en deux
il devrait à priori en récupérer un de
ces aura donc les quatre sont pour toi
une graine bang héros ivy is me
richard roy smith sharks pour toi il
apporte l'année prochaine c'est
important en flash choix et on sort une
grosse mais et java respect ça apporte
beaucoup l'année prochaine peut-être
moins sur les dix prochaines années ok -
d'être moins de plats pont pour toi chez
jabbari ce midi avant de rentrer dans
ses prospects il ya déjà des gros débat
dans le tchat avec moi vous parlez d'une
folle entre entre deux chaises et
beaucoup c'est le ski notamment
nenê
donc beaucoup plus
constant
si on rentre un peu dans le jeu du
thunder
c'est quoi leur identité de jeu on va
jouer sur quoi sur quel système
est ce que c'est une équipe qui court
que c'est une équipe qui joue beaucoup
de pick and roll est ce que c'est une
équipe qui joue beaucoup d'isolation
qu'est ce qu'elle est on constate qu'on
constate c'est que le système qu'on
utilise plus c'est là on est le moins
performant
sarr grésy le continent la
terrible c'est terrible ce qui nous
arrive josh est ce que ta ta ta ta fais
tes devoirs aussi âgé avait annulé la
petite le petit le petit gilet le petit
servette attend je me suis mis aux
couleurs de cassis
turquois bas sur ton constat sur quelle
est l'identité de jeu maintenant de
cette équipe
oui compléter sa marche non bah écoutes
je vais essayer de mon avis constant et
plus qu'avec moi pour le coup sûr ça
parce que moi je ne regarde plus tous
les matchs de quessy je vais tout à fait
sincère maintenant effectivement si j'ai
fait mes devoirs et ce qu'on voit avec
ok si c'est que avec marc daigneault ils
sont déjà dans une logique de
développement
des jeunes il ya eu il faut quand même
souligner le fait qu'il ya eu des pas
mal de blessures ces dernières saisons
il ya beaucoup de joueurs qui ont pas
joué tous les matches qui étaient là
sans être là ils ont pas jouer forcément
ensemble je pense notamment à josh qui
dit et chergui james alexander qui ont à
peine joué ensemble donc ça c'est un peu
compliqué de construire si t'as pas une
certaine continuité sur le terrain tu
comprends avec les avec ton effectif
maintenant je vois que en attaque c'est
beaucoup de jus en pick and roll c'est
du drive in teak le ballon qui ressort
sur les shooteurs
il faut absolument qu'ils s'améliorent
sur le shoot à trois points on en
parlait tout à l'heure en off avec
constant ils essaient de développer un
sens
dans leur jeu collectif et s'est trouvé
une cohésion d'équipé au delà justement
du personnel qui se trouve sur le
parquet et moi le truc que j'ai qui me
séduit le plus aujourd'hui que j'aurais
à doké si c'est défensivement
il ya un moment dans la saison jusqu'au
all star game il me semble il était top
dans l'efficacité défensive de toute la
ligue pour moi un signe un mec comme lui
d'orthe ça doit être une priorité j'ai
pas envie de trop exagéré mais mais
voilà je pense véritablement que lou
dorthe c'est un maître qu'il faut garder
khan reach williams aussi alors
qu'est-ce que quelque sorte de contrat
tu lui donnes à kadrige william e
probablement il ya une limite mais en
tout cas tous les joueurs qui te
permettent d'avoir une identité
défensive de construire cette identité
défensive tous ces joueurs là sont
extrêmement importants et je trouve que
c'est le point le plus encourageant
concernant kessy aujourd'hui hockey et
c'est vrai que alors j'avais moi aussi
j'avais pris des petites notes deuxième
meilleure défense de la ligue sur les
isolations adverse
et troisième meilleure défense de la
ligue sur le pick and roll dance et le
porteur qui va au cercle donc c'est une
défense efficace sur des des actions qui
sont beaucoup joué à l'isolation pick
and roll des choses qui sont grandes
constantes offensivement tu disais ça va
moins bien
on entend pas
c'est une galère
on est désolé pour les pour les fans du
tender qu'ils voulaient entendre
constants + moi aussi j'ai envie
d'entendre constants bah oui on a 200
envie de l'entendre
il
est censuré
avoyer envergure avoué on enfile des
idées range qui dérange
nonciature guidée en
avec hugues en janvier je crois j'avais
regardé une dizaine de matches
l'effectif changé quasiment tout le
temps donc c'était super de
en fait alex il ya plein de joueurs
qu'on a vu ici et ben ouais ouais mais à
tanger se régaler en allons voir ah
ouais moi aussi avancé il ya des gars
qui ont joué que quatre cinq matches tu
vois et qui du coup sont tout en haut de
certaines stars annoncées un peu folle
genre pourcentage de passes réussies
mais c'est vrai que ton identité
défensive elle est présente même l'année
dernière au début d'année quand il y
avait alors ford et tout ça dit les
vétérans ça défend des durs je pense que
la culture qui veut qui est dans le jeu
qui veut être impliqué c'est ok on va
perdre peut être potentiellement mais on
va pas prendre des cartons offensifs
forme de certaines formes d'art de bonne
appréhension collective sur demi terrain
faut quand même faire les efforts sa
clause à hautefort moi je trouve quand
je les vois jouer et comme le disait
josh pick and roll en attaque parce que
tu as the guide et donc guider sur lecce
le chien aussi mais que je disais pour
un joueur de 19 ans il est quand même
très avancées à la passe sur pick'n roll
alors je te passe à une autre question
là-dessus constante dès que tu peux
parler par le 6 novembre entendent et
oui mais on essaye de faire taire
bibelots sais pas par qui moi je sais
moi je sais qui c'est constant on en
parlera tout à l'heure
rien
non mais oui offensivement oui il ya des
gros soucis il ya énormément de soucis
je reviens ce jeu rebondit sur ce que tu
as dit josh waka ici avant le all star
break huitième meilleur des fausses mais
sachant que c'est énorme il ou games
d'or tu n'as aucun défenseur vraiment
élite
dans l'effectif donc ça pour le coup et
c'est une mentalité qui as tu es au
thunder depuis des années si une équipe
qui défend qui défend collectivement qui
défend dur soir saint constant c'est qui
le coordinateur défensif et au thunder
je sais pas qui est au wok à côté de
marc marc daigneault aujourd'hui au
thunder mais cette personne y est pour
beaucoup à mon avis c'est à dire qu'il
ya des schémas défensifs qui sont
extrêmement efficaces aujourd'hui ok
syrienne et il ya des oublis ce qui est
assistant
après je sais pas qui s'occupe
spécialement de la défense au pays si je
pense que c'est comme l'équipe c'est
quelque chose de collectif je pense que
les assistants ont leur mot à dire avec
marc delmotte etc
mais ensuite oui défensivement il a une
mentalité qui a inculqué et quand arrive
le cas ici même un joueur comme celle is
you say there il a énormément progressé
défensivement il a pris franchi un vrai
step et ça pour le coup c'est quelque
chose qu'on n'attendait pas vraiment on
attendait pas vraiment que tu va en
parler un jeu j y allais être énormément
explosé défensivement pour sa saison
rookie
finalement c'était pas non plus
impossible de défendre quand tu étais le
thunder avec jeudi sur le parquet parce
que tu arrivé à le cacher parce que tu
arrivé à à compenser notamment avec un
loup d'orthe même à l'intérieur on
disait oui a pas de pivot hockey ici est
l équipe qui autorisait le moins deux
paniers près du cercle où la deuxième
équipe qu'autoriser le moindre panier
prié près du cercle voilà défensivement
c'est une équipe très solide c'est
offensivement où le bât blesse vous avez
dit vous l'avez dit une équipe très
athlétique
qui manque d'efficacité notamment à
trois points
mais on picanol sixième équipe qui fait
le plus pick and roll le 28e en terme de
points par possession c'est pas possible
d'avoir un ratio fréquence de tir
réussite aussi fait
qu'est ce qui manque la taxe est le lot
point majeur
qu'est ce qui manque pour booster cette
attaque moi mon constat quand j'ai vu ça
sent en faisant abstraction des
prospects qui sont là je me suis dis
franchement un gars qui s'est bien posé
des écrans ça ferait peut-être pas de
mal ou juste une menace
cercla cercle
un gars qui est capable de poser un
écran de rouler et du coup de resserrer
la défense parce que l'efficacité sur
pick'n roll que soit le porteur caillou
bout mais aussi le roller à part mike
mills cas là mais il a une grosse
efficacité grâce aux pick and pop
parce que il y sort et une belle adresse
à trois points à part ma news ce cas là
il ya pas grand monde et d'ailleurs il
ya beaucoup de gens qui vont au cercle
du côté de hockey
tout à fait mais pour moi vraiment le ce
que tu as besoin dans cette équipe c'est
des gars qui sont capables de mettre
leurs tirs à trois points
j'ai pas la stat sous les yeux mais le
hawk eye si à un moment de la saison est
l équipe qui gérait le plus de tirs à
trois points ouvert de toute la ligne
quand quant à cette stat non pas comme
jamais en termes d'enrichissement en
drive moi j'avais promis de la ligue en
drive donc cette douane liés l'un et
l'autre probablement lié c'est à dire un
drive dans les stades c'est quand tu
pars de plus de 6 mètres et que tu
arrives à moins de deux mètres du panier
mais effectivement créé il crée cette
concentration donc y manque des gens
pour sanctionner si on résume ce que
vous avez dit les gens qui vont
s'insérer dans cette mentalité défensive
qui est déjà bonne
défensivement constant n'a pas parlé on
n'est plus sûr du switch n'est plus sûr
du edge est ce qu on sait ce que c'est
des schémas très variés à la warriors où
est ce que on est sur un schéma très
fort une identité il n'y a pas mal
d'adaptation au cours de matchs en
fonction de l'adversaire mais la plupart
du temps on est sur du switch com il ya
pas mal de switch à ok ici parce que
hormis lé site à un derrick firth qui
joue t'as pas mal de joueurs polyvalents
en fait qu'ils sont capables de défendre
plusieurs analystes basés par exemple
s'est illustré cette saison en montrant
qu'il était capable de défendre suisse
du 2 du 3 c'est voilà c'est ok ici a
confiance en son effectif et dans le
fait que quand il ya un switch son
joueur ne va pas être beau mais être
capable de rester devant son vis-à-vis
ok ça sarr grésy je te laisse refaire la
petite manip en attendant que
je te redonne la parole on va rentrer
dans la partie 2 messieurs il y est il
est temps de se demander qu'elle
prospère
ok si peu de raft et
alors on va aussi parler de
complémentarité psychologique que j'ai
pas encore je poserai la question
inconstante plus tard la garde en tête
mais une idée cité s'est pas seulement
des systèmes s'est pas seulement on joue
beaucoup de pick and roll c'est aussi
une alchimie d'equipe est ce qu on est
ce qu'on est une équipe de grande gueule
généralement il faut un petit peu de
tout dans une équipe qui a plein
d'études sur sa très intéressant
qui existe
à l'âne
en deux déjà
qui sera disponible
a augmenté au faut progresser d'avoir
une photo du board orlando mais qui
laisse tout le temps leur board
disponible au public
oui ils ont peut-être arrêter c'est new
way là ils sont 1 donc je sais pas qui
sera disponible déjà
on nous vous la chaque année il ya un
consensus qui est mis en place une
narrative par les médias les médias
draft les
influenceurs draft aux états unis qui
font les modes drac les big board et
c'est vrai que eux ils créent cette
espèce de consensus donc si on suit ce
consensus là aux questions et en deux
beaucoup de gens parlent d'une grotte à
trois joueurs ils devraient avoir soit
jabbari smith swatch est une graine soit
pour l'augmenter euros voilà bah ça va
exactement avec cette question
puisque chaque équipe aura son bord
chaque équipe aura son board qui est
complètement différent
à part et d'autre
part à de rares exceptions je pense que
ils en ont complètement rien afrique du
discours dont tu parlais la draft a trop
axé
n'diaye n'ont rien à faire
donc est ce que voudra vraiment le
meilleur joueur disponible ou est ce que
quand même on commence à s'occuper de
cette complémentarité avec des joueurs
qui jouent bien chez toi je j10 check it
out silander
même à la limite le guen sorte même si
bon il est facile à insérer dans un
roster week-end star
est ce qu'on s'occupe de ça un petit peu
quand même bah
[Musique]
personnellement moi ma philosophie c'est
non je m'en occupe pas je draft pour moi
la draft c'est là où tu vas chercher du
talent pur peu cher tc d'haïti du talent
pur peu cher et donc je vais toujours
chercher le plus aux talents que je
concède en fait j'ai toujours applaudir
une équipe qui va se dire bah je crois
toujours pas ce que c'est un gros talent
plutôt que le fit surtout que bac pro
qui si
il ya des problèmes partout alors oui il
ya un bac courte qui semble très
prometteur mais dans une nba en 2022 on
peut jouer de plus en plus avec
plusieurs porteurs de balle ont pesé de
plus en plus avec
c'est plus vraiment les schémas plutôt
archaïque de construction 1 2 3 4 5
existe avant je pense que j'irai sur le
plus gros talent au caissier a besoin de
talents comme l'a dit constant il ya des
problèmes offensifs parce que j'en mette
pas les tirs mais c'est aussi parce
qu'après de talent il n'y a pas un petit
peu sur le que les postes 3 gars tu as
créé quelque chose tout seul sur du midd
rennes jld qui peut attaquer le cercle
fait avec férocité donc et en plus on va
dire qu'il ya un alignement des planètes
parce que moi j'ai deux joueurs dans mon
tir 1 c'est en poste 4 et un poste 4-5
donc avec les timbres est donc en
réalité ça sa irai ensemble avec l'idée
que c'est un super gros talent sur un
poste où il ya peut-être un peu plus
besoin que d'autres côté du thunder bank
héros est en outre je précise oui pour
le brasero et cetto -
constants et ce qu'il faut si le thunder
maginot imagine le thunder à celle en
charge ou jedi 10 en 1 sur son bord
c'est leur joueur préféré
est ce que pour toi il faudra rester
s'il est dispo en deux du coup ce joueur
préféré haut au dessus des d autre que
toi tu elle peut-être moi je n'entends
pas là sam presti le sang sur la à ne
reprendra pas la question
la réponse est oui évidemment
il est d'accord avec toi
[Rires]
josh peux-tu répondre en attendant
conflit c'était quoi la question pardon
c'était 6 1
le joueur préféré du thunder disponible
en 2 est un arrière est ce qu'il faut à
activer le bouton ou est ce que il faut
quand même penser à développer p et donc
à créer de la valeur aussi je reviens
sur ce que disait à l'année parler de
draft et de la valeur à développer 10 10
j'ai même très mal
je suis à 300 % d'accord avec ce qu'a
dit alan au final tu te soucie pas du
fis tu te soucie pas du poste tu prends
le talent tu choisis toujours le talent
il ya trop d'exemples d'équipés qui se
sont viande et mémorablement en essayant
de coller à une construction d' équipe
alors que comme tous les très bien
rappelé à l'ats n'a aujourd'hui c'est le
positionne laisse basket ball c'est que
tu peux jouer avec quatre arrières
bientôt sur le terrain et ça n'a plus
vraiment d'importance l'important c'est
que tu es quelqu'un qui potentiellement
peut devenir le numéro 1 de ton club où
le numéro 2 donc fournir à che de quoi
avoir une seconde capables de l'épauler
dans les moments dans les moments il va
en avoir besoin
qui est capable de nourrir la marque qui
est capable de répondre à toutes ces
problématiques offensive et ça c'est que
une star ou une superstar qui peut te
qui peut aider à y parvenir donc tu
prend forcément le talent pour moi
constant je te voyais hocher la tête ça
veut dire que mes coups du coup quoi
qu'il se passe tu fais confiance puisque
en plus l'historique de prestige dans le
draft du top 10 on en parlait le soir de
la draft il est bon
oui tu entends des
problèmes non mais ça c'est le djing son
envergure tu sais c'est pas
c'est plus le jean soulard thunder dans
ce cas là mais ben moi je suis
totalement d'accord avec ce qu'a dit
alors pour moi tu n'as pas assez de
talent pour commencer à te poser de
questions du site tu prend du talent du
talent et encore du temps encore plus
quand tu montes haut dans les pics de
draft les pires choix qui ont été faits
ces dernières années c'est des choix qui
ont été faits en raisonnement du site on
peut parler d'eux en plus c'est le bon
on peut parler de 10 ans drayton qui a
été pris au sol mieux de prendre le
canon city s'est passé sortir cette
draft s'est passé pas de ça maintenant
mais si tu veux on peut parler de
wiseman qui part ou warriors alors qu'il
ya la mélo qui est le suivant je pense
que alan pour le coup a une importance
particulière à ce prix là
donc oui pour moi c'est vraiment génial
ville j'ai déjà un peu plus de réserve
celle de sharp et
pour moi pas loin d'être mon deuxième
choix en fait si chaud le grain par an 1
pour le magic
je ne serais pas surpris que ça me
précis part sur celle de chats parce
qu'ils causent beaucoup de deux points
que précis apprécié cursus universitaire
atypique très jeune gros potentiel donc
pour moi il cause dit que je serais
beaucoup de cases après s'il préfère
partir sur un smith ou sur un banc de
chéreau c'est qu'il estime pour lui que
c'est le meilleur potentiel vu le comme
tu l'as dit alex vu les historiques de
graff de sam presti peu importe qui
prend j'ai plutôt tendance à lui faire
confiance
ok même si moi j'ai mes poètes j'ai mes
préférences personnelles mais
bon si prompt à effectivement je risque
de pas être content mais
sinon
les trois autres je suis prêt à défendre
et à comprendre ce choix ok
parmi les prospects dont on a parlé on a
cité alors on a cité quatre noms je
pense
que jabbari et dans la conversation
aussi mais en même si dans nos board
personnel tous les uns les autres on n'a
pas dans le top 2
5 n'ont donc highly chars jabbari smith
paulo band chéreau chez turn one
parmi ceux-là alan
qui
qui va apporter qui va pouvoir s'insérer
plus facilement déjà dans le schéma
défensif que décrivait constant avec
beaucoup de switch quand même même si on
s'adapte donc c'est à dire de
l'intelligent de l'intelligence pardon
mes capacités à switcher
c'est plutôt déjà barry smith
parce que tschannen est un incroyable
prospects défensif hausse paix à la
protection de cercle notamment
alors voilà mais plus sûr du sweety les
plus en difficulté il est pas déjà il
fait 2 m 16 donc c'est pas non plus la
chose la plus simple tu fais de m 16 de
décès de tenir des joueurs au large et
lui il est surtout extrêmement bon sur
la lecture sur deuxième rideau et sur le
la capacité de tour de contrôle c'est à
dire que quand il est là les adversaires
ont peur d'aller au cercle ont peur de
driver parce que il fait de 16 il a une
envergure a quasiment de plus de 2,25 et
2,30 quasiment même il a un timing
incroyable pour contrer donc je pense
que l'humeur prospects défensif dans
tous les cas c'est ch est parce que chet
il te change ton système défensif il
change la manière dont les équipes vont
attaquer par contre il est surtout sur
du drop donc sur reculé sur le pick and
roll faire peur aux pertes de personnes
aillent au cercle sur le switch un tuyau
plus compliqué je pense mais
et il nécessite aussi un environnement
où à l'instar des vannes mobley à
l'instar de robert williams il faut un
autre intérieur peut être plus petit
plus costaud jo du corps pour s'occuper
sur le premier contact des intérieurs
voilà beaucoup de gens
s'y tissent dix sept hommes rennes va se
faire défoncer par joël hambye doit
faire défoncer par à dire ils seront
tous défoncés par joël envie de les
joueurs et deuxièmement son rôle lui
c'est plus de faire
ce que fait gianni skyrock lopez que
fait robert williams derrière al horford
c'est du second rideau contrer
être un défenseur playmaker c'est ce que
fait très bien tchèque avant de faire
cette prise de masse qui qui pourra sera
nécessaire pour la pour l'ennemi
employeurs prospère défensif touché m'a
convaincu ses jets mon
jeu mais je mets n'importe quoi en
tu as répondu donc à la question qui
était posée par le chat sur est il
capable produire quand a répondu en
partie sur evans mobley reconduit dans
le contexte lui oui mais renouveler le
mur prospects défensif que j'ai
quasiment vu donc je pense que
comparer les deux sait pas faire
c'est dur parce que ainsi fait pas ce
que fait mme bléhon va dira pas ce que
fait mon blé n'est pas normal en fait
parce que ce qu'il a fait en saison
rookie s'est défendu comme un vétéran
alors tu parlais d'un profil d'un autre
intérieur pour joueurs capables de jouer
à l'intérieur plus fort sur le haut du
corps capable d'encaisser 1 sur l'eau et
sur le bas d'ailleurs qu'à brève
d'encaisser le premier contact constant
est ce que donc on a des rixes est mort
c'est ce qui lui est ce qu'il est
capable de jouer ce qui peut tenir ce
rôle là de de chaperon de duch est non
pour moi j'ai vu passer le chat sauvage
ans de terreur est de retour
l'association entre dario se briser et
shuttle gré - me m'exciterait beaucoup
parce que je pense que avec darcus beese
et qui est déjà un bon combat il a
montré cette saison a commencé à devenir
vraiment très intéressant en termes de
protection de cercle contreur
intelligent qui fait pas souvent de
fautes je trouve que chet justement
pourrait fonctionner comme l'a dit halal
en tant que deuxième rideau
derrière ce buzz les pourrait sortir un
petit peu plus sur des gros intérieurs
type nicolaï ukic
pendant que chet effectivement reste un
peu plus près du cercle qui arrive en
deuxième rideau pour moi c'est une
éventualité qui
défensivement pour être viable je pense
ça dépendrait quand même que des réseaux
augmentent encore un peu plus son niveau
défensif mais si déjà très bon mais pour
moi c'est c'est pas incohérent de voir
les deux évoluent ensemble et je trouve
que défensivement comme offensivement
les deux sont plutôt très
complémentaires et que 1 bélie pourrait
de par sa qualité physique alors après
c'est pas le plus c'est pas le plus
grand c'est pas celui qui avait plus
grosse envergure c'est pas le plus tant
qu'aide à l'intérieur mais il est
largement capable en tant que premier
rideau de delic est à venir à venir
sanctionner en deuxième rideau ok c'est
un regret si comme d'habitude on
commençait à l'argent de derrick favors
parce que vous êtes bien sûr
on l'a trouvé
l ain avant de donner la parole à gauche
qui fait quoi qui est une graine
offensivement on n
en année hip hop / du picking up parce
que c'est un joueur qui était à
quasiment 40% à 3 points sur le plu
trois tentatives par match une série qui
a montré dans notre contexte que le
shoot
est une vraie arme et à 2,16 pour ça
qu'il est si spécial parce que pouvoir
shooter la sortie c'est très spécial
il finit finit bien proche du cercle pas
incroyable il peut pas trop postée il va
se faire pousser il va s'il va se faire
tancer en nba sur short roll c'est un
bon passeur mais on n'avait pas assez vu
de très bonnes situations de chartres
hall pour dire cette année il peut poser
un pic prend des décisions action après
action de cette sorte un nom je pense
qu'il va y avoir du spécisme et la porte
une menace de loeb et de la finition
proche du panier pas plus sur les
premières années c'est déjà bien parce
que ajouté à trois points au thunder
chez à l'intérieur ça va les aider je
pense si si c'est si ça se fait mais à
2,16 ses shoots et comme il le fait
c'est très rare josh pour toi est ce qui
certes est fascinant facilement dans le
roster g d'amandes alors moi j'ai une
question à vous poser quand même
concernant chet
parce qu'il ya quelque chose qui me
taraude énormément le concernant je vois
que tout le monde est extrêmement
enthousiaste le concernant et je veux
bien tout à fait croire toutes les
personnes qui me disent que du bien de
cette personne de ce joueur et je vois
pourquoi il est intrigant je vois ce qui
est séduisant dans son jeu dans ce qu'il
apporte sur le terrain maintenant j'ai
une question que j'ai envie de vous
poser c est ce qu on n'est pas face avec
son gabarit un joueur qui va vite
tourner
à l'infirmerie en fait moi c'est ce dont
j'aurais le plus fort le plus peur c'est
de voir un joueur comme lui
enfin physiquement ne pas tenir la
distance et les joueurs de cette
taille-là historiquement une billets
c'est quand même enfin c'est quand même
moi je trouve ça pas encourageant en
fait et si c'est mon club de coeur eh
ben je me pose quand même la question de
savoir est ce que le mec parce que le
taux qui progresse et qui deviennent
vraiment impactant même si à cette
histoire de comme tu dit alan de prise
de masse physique c'est justement là
aussi que ces joueurs de avec ce gabarit
là ont tendance à se blesser et on sait
très bien avec ce type de joueur si tu
te fais une sale blessure ça peux tu
peux la traînée pendant longtemps et ça
peut vite diminué ensuite et capacités
et moi ça me fait peur et ce que vous
tapez peur de ça ou pas
on sait il n'a pas d'historique de
blessures déjà non mais je veux dire pas
moi je parle par rapport à son cabaret à
son cabinet à son gabarit est
complètement gabarit l'enchaînement des
matches parce que là il exactement tu as
tout compris aux
82 matchs et un truc de dingue au fond
physiquement c'est l'intérieur au c'est
extrêmement dur il ya toujours un risque
avec un physique atypique comme le sien
c'est-à-dire un genre qui a plus de 2 15
qui a moins de 100 kg
il ya toujours un risque
après je pense que
je pense que son jeu du père mais
peut-être d'éviter de se mettre dans des
situations
de de se retrouver dans des grosses
barres bien sur wii peut toujours sur
des impacts prendre des genres dans les
genoux parce qu'il saute très haut il va
redescendre le haut du dos le haut du
corps est très soudé sous côté je trouve
il est puissant du haut du corps
il est puissant du haut du corps et line
tel standing ritz d'actionnaires les
deux bras comme ça je le montre heureux
dans le chatt qu'en fait il annihile
toute tentative de come un petit peu un
boa constrictor qui on peut pas vraiment
passé par contre sur dans les écrans la
navigation dans les écrans au rebond oui
bon d'inviter c'est la vitesse latéral
en défense par exemple est ce qu'elle
est bonne ou pas parce que s'ils se
retrouvent sur des switchs ce qu'on
parlait l'on parlait de la défense de
questi kaki est vraiment faim qui peut
être tourné vers le switch défensif et
on sait très bien comment ça se passe
ici s'il n'est pas capable de se
déplacer latéralement il va être visé
est ce qu'ils vont pas se retrouver avec
un problème aussi
aussi pénible que vive le jazz d'utah
aujourd'hui à savoir on admet en un des
meilleurs défenseurs de l'histoire de la
ligue mais dans certaines configurations
on se retrouve en b embêté parce qu' il
ne peut pas il peut pas couvrir il peut
pas les conversions corner quand il est
sous le cercle complètement has reste
c'est super intéressant c'est de la
philosophie d'or tu es jeux voire
carrément votre instrument des
limitations mais c'est vrai que moi les
intérieurs c'est pour ça que d'habitude
et je les trouve pas au parce que je
trouve qu'ils ont
un impact et une influence qui même
quand ils sont très forts pour être
moins importante qu'à d'autres postes
parce qu'il ya des limitations
athlétique des limitations de chez moi
ils sont là si je touchais sociaux c'est
parce qu'il ya le tir à trois points il
ya la capacité de passe et il ya cette
capacité tour de contrôle défensive mais
il ya des risques clairement il ya des
risques et
même si je pense qu'il est intelligent
et son jeu surtout sur le deuxième
rideau un playmaker le feq fait qu' il
ce qui ce se il a moins de chance de
vraiment prendre des coups sur le
premier contact face aux gros intérieurs
il y aura quand même toujours des
risques ça c'est clair moi le red flag
concernant cetto migraine ça serait ça
en fait ce serait seule la classe
allongée et sa longévité potentiel dans
la ligue et moi ça me ferait le beurre
parce que l'historique des ce type de
joueur en nba ne plaide pas à la halle
enfin à l'enthousiasmé à la sérénité
c'est mon opinion
c'est une opinion qui t'a fait argumente
et donc voilà
façon paulo banque héros par exemple
que peut-il faire
alors c'est un joueur j'ai vu et c'est
alan se reposer un peu et un joueur qui
est capable de driver qui est très
puissant sur sur certains appuis capable
d'alterner puissance et vitesse
capable d'être peut-être très vif sur
des appuis courts pour déséquilibrer son
adversaire c'est un joueur qui a eu des
problèmes défensifs mais n'a pas joué
pendant longtemps à cause du coc vide ce
qui pouvait expliquer aussi ses lacunes
cette saison du côté du côté de duke
par ailleurs c'est quelqu'un qui a il me
semble pris du poids en arrivant à duke
est ce qui peut aussi changer la donne
concernant et la mobilité offensive en
mobilité défensive un profil poste 4 qui
pourra prendre tirer avantage de
certains mis ce match c'est clair même
de beaucoup de mesnac
constante pour toi comment on peut
l'utiliser et ce qu'il s'insère bien
dans les line up de hockey si et je vais
mettre en en partage d'écran les line up
line up de quatre heures les formes et
line up les plus utilisés je vais pas
dire en français je me pose la question
c'est peut-être avec lui où j'ai le plus
de doutes sur sa potentielle
utilisation aux côtés d'autres joueurs
honnêtement
au niveau des line-up à 4 bat
globalement ça va être voilà du chéquier
du skylander du look et nestor du jeu je
lui dis après ça va être soit du g
reçoit de derrick may be en fonction de
qui tu fais start et parce que voilà
hockey ici et beaucoup d'interrogations
pendant une bonne partie de la saison
sur kiffar starteo post5 un moment
c'était faders étagères un coup veille
ce qui sortait du banc après la passe et
starter voilà beaucoup d'interrogations
sur le starting five et sur la rotation
intérieure du thunder par llorente en or
j'ai des doutes c'est être celui où j'ai
le plus de doute sur une éventuelle
association avec le roster actuelle du
thunder
défensivement il ya beaucoup de travail
à faire
a reconduit sa grésy encore
mais je suis désolé vraiment je suis
désolé
je vais essayer de faire court du coup
défensivement il ya beaucoup de progrès
mais je fais confiance en le coaching
staff du thunder pour le faire se bouger
un peu offensivement tu peux dire que sa
capacité de création pour les autres va
pouvoir nous aider mais pour moi c'est
quand même un joueur qui a beaucoup au
besoin d'avoir la balle dans les mains
en attaque beaucoup plus qu'un château
le grain beaucoup plus qu'un smith
7 au même niveau qu'un char pour
qu'aucun il vit par exemple mais du coup
je doute de la potentielle compatibilité
avec avec un guide y avait qu un chai
qui sont deux joueurs qui eux aussi ont
besoin d'avoir beaucoup la balle en main
chez a déjà dû s'adapter cette saison
avec l'arrivée de julie dit si tu lui
donnes un troisième gros bol hendler
avec pour lot no quiero ça fait que guy
va devoir s'adapter que chez va devoir
une nouvelle fois s'adapter pour moi ça
commence à faire beaucoup et band hero
je les dis je vais le répéter même si
son shoot pour l'instant elle correcte
il est son shoot extérieur il est
largement perfectible
donc pour moi ça commence à faire
beaucoup de points d'interrogation sur
une éventuelle association entre banques
qui reçoit
on vous remercie dans le chat on sait
que ça grésille mais il faut donner la
parole à constant qui
incessamment censuré par les instances
de deux d'internet
alan est ce que il peut avoir un petit
peu moins le ballon alors il le partage
est cette année à dublin il n'était pas
super star tout seul est-ce qu'il peut
avoir un petit peu moins le ballon et
être
aussi efficace que ce qu'on attend qu'il
soit efficace puisque pour lui pour le
coup on attend qu'ils soient efficaces
en attaque mais complètement
ce qu'on vend pour probablement 0 c'est
un joueur qui déjà physiquement
dur je pense que ça lui parle parce que
c'est un politicien lui ap ap aucune
question physique qui fait de mettre 8
115 kg c'est un ancien quarterbacks au
lycée donc il est tu l'avais dit la fed
a pris une prise de masse pour ça qu'ils
trempaient énormément sur le début
d'année à duke il est dû sortir
plusieurs fois même utérin retournent au
vestiaire pour crampes aujourd'hui ça va
ça va mieux moi je trouve qu'il ya deux
manières d'utiliser bang héros sans
ballon qui sont très intéressantes pour
tirer profit de ses qualités
premièrement en poseur d'écran et
ensuite pour prendre des décisions sur
leur trône parce que pour moi c'est le
meilleur passeur d'art à 2,8 il ya des
supers bons passeurs bien sûr il ya
toujours pour trouver des backup meneur
qui sont excellent passeur mais dans le
gratin l'année dernière pour ça que j'ai
quitté le meilleur shooteur et des
meilleurs shooteurs bien sûr mais pour
moi pour le gang quiros et meilleur
passeur et qualité de passes a surtout
le rapport taille poids qu'elle était
pas si les incroyables à 2008 de très
bonnes passes on l'a vu trouvé très bien
c'est en son intérieur sur des petits
des petits lobs faire du drive in teak
pour les shooteurs dans les coins on a
vraiment capable de le faire les passes
sont très bonnes et lectures sont très
bonnes peut-être que ça vient du passé
deux jours de football américain
peut-être ça pourrait être quelque chose
à étudier et deuxièmement je trouve que
même si c'est quelque chose qui est pas
toujours analytique la capacité pour le
band hero a créé sur le midrange est en
poste elle est
très intéressant pour un joueur de son
âge et c'est une variété quand même dans
le jeu qui même si on est beaucoup
aujourd'hui et je suis très analytique
ausy dans ma vision de la nba sur le
drive in teak le tir à trois points pas
de mes distances auxerre soit points
avant un jour quand même qui
est capable pas de prendre le ballon
allait au cercle moi j'adore les gens
qui vont au cercle provoque des
lancers-francs attaque met de la
pression sur le panier elles sont pas
que dans le tir je pense que banksy re
sur ces deux aspects la offensivement
peut aider d'emblée le jeu du thunder
jack pour ça et allen a répondu à la
question en partie de deux carats balic
du 62 qui qui est qui a été une très
bonne question est ce que c'est ce que
celle suffit pour une équipe qui veut
aller en playoffs et c'est en tant que
créateur pour lui même on parle pas de
josh qui dit qui a plus un créateur pour
les pour ça pour l'intégrer ça veut dire
des shooteurs autour est ce que pour toi
de ce que tu connais du thunder est ce
que des déchets des guides y sont aussi
capables de prendre un pas de recul
d'être
efficace en catch and shoot en catch
ndrive etc
j'ai l'impression j'ai l'impression que
c'est que c'est le cas l'adresse est
enfin l'adresse de comment il s'appelle
chase jesse alexander cette saison a un
peu baissé mais c'est aussi la saison
comment s est déroulé pour lui qui était
un peu particulière il a quand même
montré qu' il était capable de planter à
trois points que ce soit en poule up ou
sur la catch and shoot je pense pas
faire un constant tu me dis mais toi tu
connais peut-être les stats et s'est
avancé concernant de shaggy jesse
alexander mais il me semble qu'il est
tout à fait tout à fait bon je sais que
josh qui dit va bosser pendant
l'intersaison
sur son shoot c'est là vraiment un axe
de travail de l'été pour lui donc après
c'est aussi ça cette équipe c'est le
développement c'est le développement des
joueurs savoir les faire jouer off the
wall
sheth et on en parlait enfin je voulais
en parler tout à l'heure mais c'est
qu'il faut quand même avoir conscience
que chest il ya des joueurs les plus
efficaces dans le pick and roll
aujourd'hui en nba il est d'en haut
niveau des dombes seach steph curie et
trucs comme ça c'est il est absolument
élite dans le scoring en pick and roll
donc
dix ans plus tôt
iso mais en utilisation de pick and roll
aussi
gérer la stat je vais te la donner mais
ils ont tellement mais j'ai noté le g
doté la stat et
et c'est assez impressionnant voilà
c'est ça en tant qu en tant que porteur
de balle dans un pick and roll
aujourd'hui donc le point le point par
possession de tchéquie joe saunders et
1.12 ce qui fait de lui il est quasiment
dans le dans le top 20 dans le tout dans
le top de la ligue c'est plus que le cas
dont 6 h c'est plus que triangle c'est
plus que damian l'île heard et c'est un
peu moins que steph curie on en est là
quand même quand on parle de chengdu
cinq soldats il est d'ailleurs non mais
et des tutus tout à fait raison de le
souligner c'est ça qui c'est ça qu'il
faut dire c'est que quand tu vois le
personnel de tchéquie jesse alexander tu
te dis que cette stat elle est
complètement folle donc
voilà
après pour pour parler de deux banques
quéro vite fait je voulais pas posé la
question à la ddt est-ce que
défensivement on n'est pas face moi j'ai
ce que j'ai lu de lui c'est que
défensivement c'est un problème
il n'est pas il est apparemment il n'est
pas super engagés ainsi de suite tu as
tout à fait raison en disant que un mec
qui capable d'aller au cercle et de
jouer le jeu à mi distance il est
extrêmement important regarde chimie
butler aujourd'hui en playoffs c'est
exactement ce genre de ce genre de
joueur a besoin d'avoir des joueurs
comme ça surtout en playoffs
est-ce que band quéro c1 ça me fait
penser un peu en tenue et de voir ce qui
quand il est arrivé en une bière on se
disait à ce mec là en défense il est pas
bon alors que finalement nba il est
beaucoup plus engagé et il a montré des
vraies capacités qui n'était pas du tout
dans ces profils heures dans son profil
en arrivant est-ce que bancaire où cela
peut être ce genre de joueur ou pas je
vais je vais juste réponse à une
question du chat sur la transpiration a
évoqué tout à l'heure qui disait est ce
que vous n'êtes pas inquiet oui pour
rapidement une vraie bonne question
c'est des choses qui se règle facilement
avec des staffs médicaux compétents
dans d'autres sports ça existe aussi
sports d'endurance va dire ça à penser
qu'ils seront
je suis désolé mais c'est pas le même
genre mais ces mêmes cdst des gabarits
un peu maintenant je parlais de la
transpiration de banques héros à part
adacore j'arrive les crampes et cetera
ces normes normalement il n'y a pas de
problème il va bouffer du sahel jouent
pas ils allaient chez du sel avant de
rentrer sur le terrain mais vraiment il
ya plein de ya plein de solutions
et pour rebondir ce que tu disais 'je h
juste je rappelle anthony edwards quand
ils arrivent en lumière quantifier les
tests physiques juste avant d'arriver il
est
99e percentile
surtout temps d'accélération force de
décélération forces latérales c'est à
dire que c'est l'athlète ultime ultime
au niveau de l'explosivité
antonier dans
évidemment al anbaa tu répondes mais il
faut avoir en tête que anthony edwards
ce n'est pas tout le monde aimait les
pros général les freshman sont les le
freshman rainsy est hélas le contexte
plus difficile pour moi évalué
défensivement veine simons était un
défenseur anémique et déçus parce qu'on
en fait ça dépend évidemment du contexte
dépend énormément de l'engagement et
c'est pas parce que beaucoup souvent dix
ans il n'a pas défendu en une vieille
défendre apparemment ça marche pas comme
ça des fois quand a énormément de
responsabilités action après action tu
te reposes un petit peu des fois ces
limitations physiques très longue défend
dépend a initié il défend pas très peu
en nba mais pour anthony edwards on en
parlait or il n'avait aucune
appréhension collective défense il est
beaucoup d'erreurs mauvaise lecture du
jeu et qui cherchait toujours
l'interception
oui mais on a dit alex plus plus jeune
simone celui qui défend des pas trop
mais son profil athlétique est tel que
arrive à une biais dans un staff quand
on comprend vraiment pour tirer
l'avantagé tiré profit d'un joueur on
sait le faire donc banque héros il ya
des vraies questions sur sa défense sa
latéralité fait ça c'est pas un athlète
incroyable arrive à léo certes mais son
premier pas n'est pas incroyable et donc
ça se répercute en défense du fait qu'
il peut il se fait souvent passer par
les porteurs de malades vers ce
mois je pense comme comme sur le poste 4
il va devoir surtout défendre des délits
jean qui acquitteront un petit peu plus
petit que lui mais qui seront pas non
plus véloce du monde alors les
meilleures cibles leçons mais
je suis pas extrêmement inquiet pour sa
défense ça sera pas un défenseur
stoppeur pousse plus mais je suis pas je
pense je vois pas un red flag comme
certains le
défenseur stoppeur que ailier que peut
être déjà d' harry smith par exemple si
selon certains oui parce que j'aimerais
c'est hyper active des barry smith aléas
les mains extrêmement
toujours sur le ballon javaris mais
c'est toujours dans l'intensité et même
si c'est pas le plus vertical ou
compense par une suractivité qui fait
qu'il est vraiment embêter les joueurs
adverses et l'incertain forme de
polyvalence certains ne sont pas
d'accord ou dans le chat on en parle
souvent il n'est pas d'accord sur sa
capacité à switch moi je trouve que
c'est pas la chose qui fait le plus mal
mais oui il trouvait que la noblesse
avait des hanches trop alors là êtes
immobiles c'est pas un homme un dribble
tout est bon tout le monde a ses fesses
et fait des erreurs et c'est bien normal
mais
en fait c'est vrai que on parle beaucoup
des problèmes de défense de de polo déjà
juke depuis 5 6 ans des schémas
défensifs c'est c'est très compliqué de
défendre dans les équipes des joueurs
qui se connaissent pas de joueurs qui
n'ont jamais joué ensemble on se
rappelle de l'époque et marc d'une bague
les wines of carter obligé de passer en
zone parce que c'était impossible de le
défendre après marvin bagley coup ne
comptent toujours rien ne comprend
toujours pas mais wayne hall carter est
un bon défenseur un très bon processeur
et pourtant on n'arrivait pas à mettre
un schéma pour des trains et les gares
et rennes dans cette équipe aussi qui
est pas non plus horribles sur les
extérieurs en défense mais là il joue
avec des joueurs qui l'avait jamais
jouée trois premières années dans le
cinq de départ
pas beaucoup d'expérience donc qu'ils
ont fait en fait chaud qu'ils ont ils
ont collé ils ont ils ont essayé de
coller des boues pour que ça passe ce
n'était pas le meilleur contexte mais
c'est pas un défenseur stoppeur ultime
falls
on est en train de déborder si le chat
vous en avez marre vous nous dites mais
vous êtes toujours 160 à nous regarder
en direct c'est ce qui me pousse souffle
merci d'être là
mais on va continuer parce que on parler
de chartes et pour moi c'est une vraie
possibilité
j'avais dis d'ailleurs à constant quand
j'étais passé sur le live soir de la
loterie j'avais dit s'il ya une équipe
du top 3 qui doit prendre sharks pour
moi c'est ok si papa qui doit mais qui
peut
par rapport à l'historique etc ou
constant est ce que tu vois je montrais
les line up tout à l'heure les plus
utilisés
est-ce que tu ne vois s'insérer dans une
rotation à court terme puisque c'est un
joueur qui va avoir besoin de jouer un
moment des matches officiels en
arrière on va y avoir une problématique
qui va se poser vis-à-vis de l'ong
exhorte fatalement
parce que voilà je suis dj did you say
there sont des logs danton starting five
tu en a un qui va jouer postera de le
deuxième qui va jouer poste 2
post 3 bat elle cite un shakedown sharp
forcément va y avoir un moment où on va
dire comment tu peux l'utiliser
soit avec gigi ou et celle du diocèse
under ou alors comment tu vas l'utiliser
tout en essayant de continuer à bien
utiliser lugano sorte une solution qui a
été un peu expérimenté par okai si ça
commence à remonter monde la bulle
c'était lugentz d'or tant poseurs
d'écran au poste 4 ça a été fait ça des
loups d'or tu es tellement tanks et
qu'il est capable d'avoir cette ce rôle
de poseurs d'écran et dans ce cas là tu
peux avoir
un chef de charte qui se retrouve au
poste 3 qui est du coup un peu plus de
créativité et tu peux faire cohabiter
les quatre ans sont surtout que
défensivement jeudi 10 et très grand
chez guillou sa grandeur est pas le plus
petit des arrières t'as pas un déficit
de taille monstrueux en fonction de qui
tu meures post 5 tu n'as pas déficit de
taille monstrueuse situe mais lugano
sorte au poste 4 donc oui il ya une
question qui se pose je pense si ondraf
sheridan chat qui sera utilisé d'abord
en sortie de banc
on gardera les les trois du bac ou
pendant un certain temps et si vraiment
shannon sharpe avec des minutes bien
évidemment hochart peut utiliser avec
guide icher etc mais on restera vers
cette stabilité du bac courte et si
vraiment chars explose tout parce que je
pense qu'il est capable de faire il ya
un moment où il y aura une question qui
va se poser sur logan sorte est-ce que
tu mets en sixième homme défenseur en
sortie de banc est ce que tu décale au
poste 4 pour moi c'est une question qui
va se poser mais ça pour moi c'est un
problème de riche
c'est pas vraiment une interrogation qui
me fais avoir des sueurs froides en y
pensant pour moi c'est bah ouais tu un
défenseur qui est potentiel défensif tim
et si tu prends sharp hors d'eux secte
estime qu'il a un potentiel de superstar
donc pour moi c'est c'est vraiment moi
je prends pour avoir ce genre de
problème tous les jours qui s'y
cachent quelle question tu te poses sur
celle chat
on en a parlé vite fait tout à l'heure
avec constant off moi ce qui me dérange
c'est le fait qu'il n'est absolument fin
on n'a pas à part ces années au lycée on
n'a
rien d'autre à se mettre sous la dent
donc c'est un peu compliqué je trouve ce
genre de deux profils ça me semble un
peu risqué de se baser là dessus sur un
pic de maintenant quand tu rates son
profil ça a l'air effectivement très
très encourageant
très séduisant
voilà moi je voulais savoir
les
quelles sont les principales
qualités de ces trois qualités qui sont
qui font qu'il ferait que ce mec-là ce
soit
un pic justifiable avec le deuxième le
deuxième choix de la draft
pourquoi pourquoi on en est là
aujourd'hui tous les quatre a parlé de
ce à quoi
que c'est possible a dit alan moi j'ai
un complément de réponse je pense mais
je te laisse moi je commence et où finit
le la capacité ajoutée en sortie de
dribble c'est peut-être c'est la chose
la plus rare dur c'est sûrement lui qui
est sa de mieux dans cette dans cette
cuvée comme tu l'as dit il a
pour le grand public qui on se base que
sur du lycée c'est vrai
nom l'a aussi vu en fiba avec la mène au
canada c'était quand même bien trois ans
pour quand même je veux dire c'était il
ya trois ans et en 2019 un tournant u16
et on l'a aussi vu alors chez qu'en
france c'est très impopulaire en ue
donc en vous et ivoiriennes opus
circuits parallèles de nike aux états
unis qui sur lequel je vous
regarde beaucoup de ses joueurs de ses
de ces matches là depuis un an
maintenant et qui apporte un complément
pour moi je trouve à l'évaluation
puisque plus être contexte que je trouve
ça intéressant de voir les joueurs
maintenant c'est vrai n'a pas le
contexte haussier il n'a pas joué de
match officiel depuis septembre
quasiment où il a fini ses emplettes il
a fini son cursus high school avant
qu'il a pu aller à kentucky plus tôt et
faire un semestre ce qu'on sait par
contre d un fossé qui veulent étaient
des gens qui l'ont vu site il était
dominant dans tous les entraînements
luthiste et les meilleurs joueurs
mentalité plus poussé les choses compter
sur l'écran on avait un petit peu de
questions comme les qualités de passes
on n'avait pas si je vais retenir trois
qualités pour répondre la capacité à
attirer en sortie de dribble et d'une
pureté très impressionnante la
verticalité aussi pour finir proche du
panier
et je dirais et la rareté du profil
parce que c'est rare ce genre de jour là
donc ça sera tout mais on n'a pas vu
défendre dans d'énormes contexte on l'a
très lu peut défendre on l'a pas trop vu
passer ya beaucoup beaucoup de questions
autour de lui quand je t'entends j'ai
l'impression que ça peut potentiellement
être un des tout meilleurs joueurs de
cette draft en fait
pour moi car alors mon complément de
réponse était si on en parle josh à mon
avis c'est aussi parce que le haut de
cette draft est pas extraordinaire -
coup sûr
c'est à dire qu' il n'aurait jamais été
dans la même conversation que quelques
nine gamme l'année dernière même si il
sait aussi il ya un monde dans lequel il
va faire une meilleure carrière cocaïne
une mineure mais tu vois je suis
personne mais
le mettre dans la même conversation que
kate même mob les ogrines l'année
dernière je pense qu'il n'aurait pas été
sans jouer en est fier maintenant
il ya aussi des rapports en cours de
saison qui disent que il a amélioré son
jeu de passes qui disent qu
il a bien défendu il sait bien démerdé
sous la pression en dribbles si le hand
hall était un petit peu problématique
pour ceux qui sont dans le chapeau qui
veulent le connaître on a fait un peu de
casse de 45 minutes sur lui on va pas il
passé 45 minutes aujourd'hui mais si
vous voulez vraiment rentré dans le
détail ici on tire les grandes lignes et
surtout le met dans le contexte ok si
la question je te pose halal est ce
qu'il est capable et je vais juste
mettre ses mensurations puisque elles
sont tombées hier au combat et que j'ai
beaucoup aimé les mensurations
charmasson
sont d'un goût
et il n'a pas fait le ps de détente
parlait en fait pour les autres restent
pour les autres normalement voilà bah
non non non officiel c'est 49 inc
quasiment un mètre de détente sèche
choisi alex beh l'écouté de podcast
maintenant là c'est bon pas convaincu le
savez ça va ça va on a compris laissez
une officine ont officiellement interdit
donc à ce qui était sortie sur les
réseaux sociaux et sachant que le plus
haut il a 41 lui sera 49 complètement ma
boule mais
alan est ce qu'il a besoin du ballon on
avait hâte ans j'avais la question dans
le
mais il ya beaucoup de participation
voilà est-ce que c'est un score fleuve
est ce que c'est un initiateur et du
coup comment
s'articulerait constant a commencé à en
parler du côté de ok si score ballaman
il les deux groupes quand on l'avait vu
la première fois en 2019 il était
totalement hors ball ou parce qu'ils
savaient pas encore tirées donc ont
profité de ses capacités athlétiques sur
des cut sur des choses comme ça et en
fait pourquoi on parle de shedden sharp
c'est parce qu'en fait on en parle
depuis un an parce qu'en fait ça a été
le meilleur joueur et le mvp du circuit
et you l'été dernier lité 2021 il a
absolument détruit tout le monde en fait
et des baux déjà qu'ils sont pas des
accents passé initier des futurs lottery
pick l'an prochain c'était meilleur
joueur en fait c'était le meilleur
joueur est en fait ils n'étaient pas
classées dans pas mal de big board en
fait les gens se sont dit non c'est que
ça c'est que du vélo mais ils ont été
voir les matches ils se sont dit ok il
ya quand même des choses à tirer là
dessus et il a amélioré cette capacité à
attirer en fait en sortie de dribble ou
maintenant il peut couleur de très loin
très avec beaucoup l'efficacité sur coup
la plaie souvent surévalués les des
mesnils art ces gens là ils sont pas
plus de 35% à 3 points et il ya que
stephen curry ou ces jours là qui sont à
plus parce que c'est des extraterrestres
site est déjà à 33 34 35 % sur un an au
volume sur du colloque de loin c'est à
dire bien très bien donc
je pense qu'en fait je rejoins vraiment
ce que tu as dit profitent du contexte
de cette draft il profite du contexte
par poste de cette draft je vais
conserve beaucoup de bollène leur
capable de tirer en sortie dribbles et
donc celle un score fleuve pour
l'instant clairement c'est plus un
scoreur qu'un créateur c'est un joueur
qui a besoin du ballon ça jure qu a
vécue sans ballon mais c'était il ya
longtemps et on n'a pas vu vivre sans
ballon depuis un an et demi que facile
les équipes tournent beaucoup autour de
lui depuis un an
incroyable de 6 points lé le monde sur
as you du jeune homme je ne veux pas
mettre en plus grand or donnerait
donc
625 de tête c'est doit être dû en 96 ans
81 55 à toi
est donc une mine span 2 de m 12 ouais
ça presti doit aimer ça
l'espace à mort landau peut aimer aussi
il a des
voix là pour faire pour faire simple
constant dans l'ordre de priorité
vas-y tu es là tu étais dans le fauteuil
sam presti
et à ton bord d'affaires fait on board à
faire
c'est quoi ton ordre de priorité donc ce
qu'on appelle le bar
mon ordre de priorité qui n'est que le
mien parce que je sais que sur le compte
il va pas être partagé en ses jets pas
de débat je pense qu'en 2
ses chats honnêtement je pense qu'en 2
sur mon ordre d'achat en 3g bonne
clairon encadrés jabari et en sac
j'ai avis il vraiment
si vraiment le gars tu te rends fou sur
les workouts et qui te donne
l'impression d'avoir un potentiel
illimité mais vraiment dessous des 4 au
hockey avis on en a pas parlé parce que
j'ai mal géré le temps
mais voilà c'est un arrière qui va très
très vite on parle souvent du premier
pas moi je trouve qu'il va plus vite sur
le deuxième pacte quinquis et surtout
impressionnant son deuxième papa
mais parle à parler des détails alan est
ce que tu partages le board non toi t'as
pas le même board mais même dans le
contexte ok si puisque ce qui est
intéressant dans les bornes c'est
parfois aussi de faire des bornes
spécifiques d'un complètement
si tu devais faire un board pour ok si
moi c'est ça la mjc partira sur la même
chose même même si je préfère djanadi a
déjà barry smith peut-être même que je
prendrai peut-être même déjà barry smith
pour dégeler dans le même tiers que des
danaïdes vie donc il fera par action
serait plus sensé qu'on n'en a pas parlé
il ya une très grosse hype sur lui
rennes demain à août ici à part son tir
il est d'emblée parce qu'un joueur de
mettre 10 qui tire comme quel potentiel
pour tirer comme prime rashard lewis
d'arrivée tout de suite en nba ça aide
donc ils feraient sens je pense qu'avec
en plus l'activité défensive et la
qualité de passe il ya des limites dans
ton je pense qu'il ya peut-être moins de
super stars potentielles que jedi vie
mais il serait extrêmement de sans sarah
houcke ici
josh parce que tu as entendu
c'est quoi ton scénario idéal pour ok si
c'est ce que tu avais des questions pour
chaque joueur il ya des personnes qui
étaient vraiment tous toi tu es plus
style jabbari
de ce que j'ai pu lire en préparant
cette émission je serai plus team
jabbari et alan vient de résumer très
bien
probablement parce que shoot défense
il ya eu jamais rien de sûr dans les
draft ça c'est un truc qu'on apprend
très vite quand on s'occupe de genre de
choses va vous le mieux placé pour le
savoir et peut-être que d'avoir
justement ce mec là qui au mieux devient
un super rôle player peut-être tu vas
afin de dans le pire des cas
je trouve ça plutôt bien maintenant
cetto graines non donc quand je vous
écoute je me dirais sharp en premier
potentiellement je serai à tête brûlée
gillet j'irai chercher ce mec là si
vraiment il a le potentiel que vous
décrivez jabbari smith parce que ça m'a
l'air d'être d'être un bon profil
tchedji me fait peur moi personnellement
voilà et banque héros je sais pas j'ai
pareil c'est pas le genre de ce n'est
pas le genre de joueurs rouge et qui me
fait pas confiance quand je vois c'est
son descriptif mais mais je me trompe
peut-être totalement vous êtes bien plus
qu'avec moi sur ce genre de questions
aux personnes
non mais je veux dire voilà c'est pas
quelqu'un qui me qui me khimki moscou
maintenant j'ai une question pour alors
on a dix sept équipes dont kiel si elle
a déjà son option et on était un peu
tous d'accord là dessus et josh nous a
encore plus mis d'accord avec les stats
en option numéro un non mais c'est vrai
le l'option numéro 1 de hockey si quoi
qu'il arrive l'année prochaine ce sera
cher ça on est à peu près d'accord là
dessus du coup alan est ce que ça vaut
vraiment le coup dans cette draft de
draft est un gars et là je parle
peut-être deux banques héros parce
qu'aucun grain c'est un cas différent
qui
qui peut être ton meilleur joueur
ou est ce que ça vaut le coup d'attendre
un an deux ans pour draft est un gars
qui peut vraiment être une superstar est
ce que bang héros ça peut être le gratin
de la ligne ça peut être un top d'un
joueur
oui ça peut être un top 20 mais je pense
pas que ça peut être le meilleur joueur
d'une équipe qui va au titre
mais ça peut être un
excellent ça peut être un excellent
élévateurs de plancher est un excellent
une excellente deuxième option mais qui
nécessiterait la développement du tir
extérieur pour en complément d'une star
qui serait sourd sûrement plus petit
écart est sûrement plus la balle mais
tu me demande aujourd'hui je pense que
je fais un char a plus de chances d'être
les meilleurs jouent le meilleur joueur
d'une équipe qui vise le titre que par
le banquier rossi les deux scénarios les
deux meilleurs scénarios se font pas la
banque y aura sûrement moins de chance
d'être un mauvais joueur du ch et d'un
chat mais c'est qui ce qu'il faut se
poser tout en ayant de 6 en tête 2023
comme tu dis parce que 2023
potentiellement a déjà pour moi deux
voire trois joueurs qui peuvent être
dans le baratin de la nba donc
pas bonne à dire
c'est au sort thompson
l'homme qui peut nier puis faire un lay
up et dunk et dans la même action ainsi
j'en ai douce et de l'eau d'heure
climbing
mais c'est super intéressant parce que
moi je prendrais comme ce que je pense
être le meilleur joueur le maire alors
même si c'est pas peut-être suite il va
peut-être être un meilleure option et
leur zone même dans les grands cette
théorie du le mauvais initiateurs ouais
complètement aléatoire d'une mauvaise
équipe la meilleure joueur de l'us
random et ont exécuté leurs risques sur
ce genre de job normal c'est pas gentil
on l'aimé charles x en commune c'est
vrai mais même si tu veux être vraiment
méchant tu peut presque dire damiani là
j'applaudis
trop fort trop fort pour être choisi oui
je vois c'est vrai ce que tu dis en même
temps si on attend dans une grave de
draft est toujours un futur top 5 et
n'diaye monsieur pour moi des superstars
capable de mener leur équipe au titre
qu'importe le contexte chaque année il y
en a à quoi 5,6 mais encore donc mais
c'est mais c'est hyper intéressant parce
que ça nécessite une raffinerie pour le
bang héros saffré que ta chère guider
bankir au l'année prochaine tu vas
revenir dans le top 4 5 tu devras quand
même réfléchir à son équipe même si même
moi je suis un pape du du talent sur le
titre qui devra quand même penser à ça
donc sa draft là en deux elle a comme de
l' influence sur les prochaines années
aux caisses qui quoi qu'on en vende
rester
et du coup ce qui est intéressant pour
revenir là dessus et après on parlera
avec constant des pics 12 et 30 de ce
qu'il a envie de comme profil puisse
bien la plus intéressante bien plus en
plus des petits coups on va se demander
sur le fixe
ce qui ce qui est intéressant c'est que
chet par exemple et même gabarit dans
une moindre mesure ils sont peut-être
plus complémentaire peut-être plus
capables d'être des joueurs qui vont
être seconde option d'une éventuelle
superstar un jour que paolo bancaire au
shannon sharpe je ne sais pas parce que
je les ai vu que en position de
superstar en position de super
porteur de balle qu'elle doit tout faire
j'ai fini ma question
c'est pour constant d'accord non
seulement c'est bon un pardon excusez
moi
oui oui clairement le la scalabilité
pour reprendre un mot utilisé aux états
unis tu as barry smith et de livrer aux
activités audience l'évolutivité
exactement ça veut dire la capacité à
peser dans une équipe quand quand le
contexte n'est pas le meilleur pour
soi-même seront souvent quand on n'a pas
le ballon en réalité on va pour pas mal
de joueurs j'ai déjà barry smith par son
tir est incroyable parce qu'un joueur de
sa taille qu'il prend autant de tirs à
trois points avec une telle efficacité
qui peut aussi fait exception du midi
sens aussi facilement sera utile dans
tout contexte cet homme rennes paris
pour la défense c'est parce que leur
niveau d'évolutivité plus important que
que sharp est en cuir au messie sharks
ça marche les vous l'utilisez évolutive
dans la met de côté parce que ça peut
être cette superstar bon moment ça peut
être sympa de se dé ça peut être un des
vignes booker voilà si c'est le meilleur
scénario de cette enchère pour moi
c'était vignes bouquin
or plus athlétique la cepal sais pas
mais c'est pas des grands c'est pas une
vitesse très très impressionnante sur le
premier pas mais c'est des longs
segments d une capacité de s'élever au
dessus du défenseur et on s'est alors
évidemment les apôtres du court terme
vont dire que des vignes coeur s'est
fait dessus dans un match 7 mais ça
arrive à beaucoup a mis 40 points de
beaux matches de suite dans des finales
nba
bien sûr et tu t'es bien leur
constant josh la même question
pic 12
quel profil
aux planches eux au plancher et moins de
plafond linverse c'est à dire on draft
au potentiel et jette encore le d il ya
aussi un pic 30 tu peux vous poser la
même question pour le puits de 30
constant je les sens
déjà est-ce que tu piques en 12 et
entrantes c'est la question très bonne
question
je pense que sam presti
s'il a un coup de coeur sur un joueur ou
si un joueur qui baisse on a parlé quand
était passé sur le live au monde la
loterie si lg griffin encore disponibles
en 8 ou 9 pour moi ça me précis doit
appeler il doit absolument essayer de le
récupérer parce que le on parle que ce
soit en termes de fitou que ce soit en
termes de potentiel il serait très bien
ok ici alors oui après je sais il ya le
dossier médical où il ya des red flag et
c est pour moi c'est vraiment le joueur
que tu doit cibler en priorité avec ton
deuxième pic si jamais tu as envie de
monter
après la tue la fiche
à ousmane dia par exemple c'est pas le
genre de profil que j'ai envie de voir
au cas ici
la maison est en désaccord avec le avec
ce que pense un précis mais pour moi on
12 faut que tu commences à drafté des
joueurs qui ont un plancher un minimum
élevé que tu arrêtes de faire des paris
à tout va
c'est à dire que toile et les beaucoup
et c'est en attaque lac tu vois il en
fait j'ai envie de voir un petit peu de
stabilité au thunder des joueurs qui à
partir du moment où tu auras ta star
seront déjà productif tu seras pas en
mode il faut encore attendre un an ou
deux ans pour que ça se développe moi ça
à partir du moment où tu auras une
équipe et tu auras une volonté d'être
réellement compétitif peuvent apporter
directement moi tu veux un profil mais
calbry jays en fin de notre jambon c'est
ça c'est ça c'est ça
lemmy cambridge d'ailleurs je pense que
l'essonne sont très contents de la voir
et que nous on serait très content de
l'avoir aussi évoqué ici tout le monde
serait content d'avoir un mickaël bridge
il ya des joueurs de villanova dans
cette draft mais sont projetés un peu
plus bas
je rêve je prends juste une question à
l'oral avant avant de laisser josh
s'exprimer sur ce qu'ils 12 mai 10 qui
demande à quel point l'âge est important
il revient sur le pic deux halal c'est
pas facile pas facile à répondre comme
question mais en gros les quatre les
quatre ils se tiennent en un an mais
chase est le plus vieux à celle plus
vieux chat a déjà 20 ans il dit avoir
hissé le plus jeune âge à paris c'est
plus jeunes avec shark plus est le plus
jeune mais du tri les forêts du trio
louis mémoire oui du trio on peut
annoncer c'est déjà par sms le plus
jeune et cette liste est important oui
c'est basique en scouting là je mets
plus entre un joueur de 19 ans un joueur
de 23 ans là on parle de joueurs qui se
tiennent quand même quelques mois donc
c'est moins important par contre c'est
pour ça que les gens de 18 19 ans
partant d'un top 10 parce que ils sont
moins fini ça soit physiquement ce soit
dans le jeu donc qui approche de
matériel à développer chez eux d'un
joueur de 23 ans mais l'âge il est très
important
mais par rapport du coup pour autrement
dit entre eux ça le sera probablement
assez peu moi je pense dans la liste
des priorités donc
qui nous propose évidemment john butler
en douce je vais afficher notre board
pendant que josh répond à la question
sur le pic 12 quel genre de profil pour
toi il faudrait choisir sa presse et on
sait qu'il faut que tu fasses confiance
dans son équipe de scouting pour avoir
identifié les talents
je ne sais pas d'ailleurs comment est
classée comment vous jugez le les
équipes de quessy là dessus comment
j'ai enfin leur capacité à juger les
talents justement c'est faudrait faire
un classement comme ça par club nba
savoir qui est qui s'en sort le mieux
moi je vois avec un pic 12 effectivement
constant et la raison est ce que tu es
ce que tu en pic 12 ectopique 30 est ce
que tu les prends ou est-ce que tu les
prends pas la question et éventuellement
se poser maintenant si je suis ok si je
pique déjà en deux avec le 12 août
essaie de trouver pour moi tu vas
chercher un joueur avec un
gros gros potentiel qui n'est pas
évident maintenant mais qui peut 2 qui
peut tout ce jour-là peut devenir une
superstar à l'avenir quoi et quand je
parle de ça je parle de vous donner un
exemple j'ai dit sortez tout comme pau
quand il est choisi quand il est choisi
par les bucks il est pris en 15e
position est la seule vidéo qu'on ait de
ce mec là c'est dans un gymnase
en train de jouer au basket c'est ça
tout ça paraît très très flou et
d'ailleurs ça refroidit pas mal
d'équipés aujourd'hui n'importe qui
prendrait à gedeon tout comme pour en
premier pour son équipe de demain quoi
voilà kawaii léonard a été choisie qu'en
15e position
quand tu vois le nombre de joueurs qui
aujourd'hui sont
des frenchies player ou des options
numéro un ou deux dans des certaines
équipées de billets
ya des joueurs qui sont co était prêt au
second tour
ce que je veux dire par là en disant ça
c'est que l'on est souvent là à discuter
des premiers pics de grave parce que
c'est ce qui nous paraît être importants
et ainsi de suite or l'histoire nous
montre souvent que tu as quand même pas
mal de joueurs des pépites qui se trouve
dans le ventre mou des draft voir au
second tour ça c'est peut-être un peu
plus rares mais mais mais tu as sûrement
une très bonne pioche à faire quoi et
moi j'aimerais voir que voilà je pense
que ok si avec le nombre de drague de
plis de draft qui l'ont ils peuvent se
permettre d'aller tester quelque chose
alors peut-être qu'effectivement les
fans doc et six en ont marre de voir des
tentatives qui sont pas forcément
convaincante à leurs yeux mais je sais
pas si tu as
si tu as autant de piques que tu t'y vas
quoi tu testes je tente voilà après ce
qui est sous côtés quand on parle de ces
history janis et et kawaï c'est qu'ils
sont quand même mal évalués sur leurs
plafonds généralement puisque les deux
jouent assez rapidement ce qui permet de
les développer c'est à dire que et si et
si et ce qui freinait les équipes du roi
allait prendre c'était aussi ça c'était
on se disait ça peut être complètement
un flop c'est sûr mais à y regarder
c'est aussi une des questions les plus
importantes pour moi en tant que fan de
nba c est ce que le club est ce que mon
club a démontré ces dernières saisons sa
capacité à développer des jeunes talents
c'est une question qui est primordial
aujourd'hui parce que tu peux avoir des
jeunes des jeunes joueurs qui ne
demandent demande qu'à être développé
est ce que tu as la structure en place
pour pour y parvenir si je regarde les
knicks et j'ai pas envie de taper sur
les knicks c'était trop facile mais si
tu vois les knicks est toujours une
difficulté à développer les jeunes chez
eux quoi c'est ici le style et si les
joueurs draftés là bas sont pas
opérationnel tout de suite l'impression
qu'ils vont ils vont passer à la trappe
ou coup ça s'est compliqué quoi je sais
pas alors tu as des clubs il s'en sort
de mm on a deux philosophies différentes
on a le board sous les yeux oui on a
d'un côté constant qui veut
amicale bridge
c'est ce qui ne se trouve pas sous le
sabot d'un cheval
qui sont les candidats être le mais le
magal bridge hisse parmi ceux que convoi
entre notre 8e et 17e position ici
johnny davis jérémy foshan donc jérémy
sociale et le polonais le l'anglo
polonais je tiens à le préciser ligne en
angleterre il joue avec la pologne
l'anglo polonais de baylor qui
est un poste 4-5 id&t me former meneur
en europe avant d'aller aux états unis
qui a un fort défenseur un groupe lui et
qui est un genre extrêmement intéressant
avec le tir à aller là dessus mais il a
19 ans donc il a clairement le potentiel
johnny davis et au chac bagis sont plus
des joueurs qui pourraient plaire à
constant qui sont des joueurs qui sont
plus âgés les genres référent sera
initié si ceux qui ceux qui peuvent
prendre un costume en nba de rôles
tertiaire dans leur contrat rookie je
pense c'est à dire défendre m des tirs
faire peu d'erreurs qui ont peut-être un
potentiellement illimitée que les autres
je pense que tu avec ses trois jours
l'adice moi j'aime beaucoup dyson
daniels dans un profil pour provoquer si
l'australie puis en russie les
australiens et l'ajout angelides donc ça
me prestige va le prendre donc
qui est un profil
excellent défenseur je trouve sur
l'homme qui ont à se mettre des paniers
qui gêne encore moi je suis un peu plus
comme jo j'ai envie de prendre le risque
était en 12 j'ai cherché du talent mais
je comprends tellement aussi de la
philosophie de constant qui ait envie de
joueur un peu sur voilà qui se dit ok
c'est
déjà donnez moi un joueur que je vais
pouvoir prolonger sur le deuxième
contrat qui va remplir son rôle et qui
va fluidifier la taxe ne pas faire
d'erreurs défensives tout en ayant quand
même un certain potentiel parce qu'elle
est toujours en loterie [ __ ] à reprendre
non plus un joueur de 24 ans
sans énorme potentiel le meilleur séjour
de ces genres de gens là je pourrai
pourrait m'intéresser si je suis si
choqué si avec en plus pour moi le le
catch à la une du raid signalé une durée
n'est là
en 12 ha ok si je le prends c'est un
joueur qui n'a pas encore 19 ans est un
pivot
terrorisant physiquement c'est à dire
que j'ai jamais vu un pivot de son âge
avec un corps pareil mais tout est à
faire sur le sur le scoring sur
l'appréhension mais et
ça peut être un diamant brut défense hu
moi j'aime bien du réel
qui tua en potentiel élevé à ce niveau
là parce que pour le coup ils vont
peut-être pas être notées dans
dans le consensus à votre manche du
world donc moi 304e donc malakal brennan
en 11 ohio state
blake worsley notter game
dyson daniel je suis plutôt choses sur
lui gelé en 15
cl constante du plus sûr aussi il ya du
harrison ingram potentiellement un
joueur très intelligent de stanford mais
voilà le tsigane qui gagnent murray qui
est quand même annoncé top 5 par les
américains qui musée serait étonnant
qu'ils soient leurs il sera pas là je
pense mais moi je le suis un peu moins
fan donc j'ai décidé que ce serait un
très bon joueur nba il plaira constant
en 12 parce que kilian murray en réalité
il a au plancher ils arrivent ils à voir
est utilisé très facilement
offensivement avec un moins de potentiel
que d'autres mais c'est toujours cette
ce set dualité à ce moment de la draft
est ce que tu vas encore chercher un
potentiel ou est ce que tu vas chercher
un genre plus sûres donc
c'est ça va être le débat ça m'intéresse
beaucoup de voir ce qu'ils vont faire là
dessus
moi j'ai plein de mecs un peu floue à ce
niveau-là genre peyton watson et bryce
mcgowan ce qu'ils sont vraiment des
dés jetés mais mais qui ont
effectivement un fort potentiel
dit qu'ils gagnent leur est trop ça
ressemble à auby copine
c'est méchant et en même temps il s'en
sort un peu mieux ouais carrément ça va
mieux pour vie
mais oui si janet de rennes tombe 12
j'active tous les jours le bouton parce
que pour le coup il peut avoir une
utilité d l'année 1 et en plus
voilà contribuer un peu plus tard et
être ce gros bosseur d'écran qui sans
moi et pour un petit peu un défaut dans
le jeu
on a fait déjà nono board on a parlé du
pic 12 est-ce que constant je te mets
juste titre question comme ça est ce que
tu as envie de le pic avec le 30 et 34
ou est-ce que ça fait peut-être trop de
jeunes ce que tu vas les échanger pour
du cash pour je sais prendre un européen
peut-être les laisser en europe
pensez-vous aussi mais qui à
l'europe pour moi cette formule qu'il
connaît bien de rocky pas plus deux ou
trois russes tu draft en deux et tu te
débrouilles pour essayer de monter en
sept ou huit ans un package 12 30 34 tu
as bien des équipes qui vont prendre ça
je pense que il ya tellement peu de
différence entre un joueur qui pourrait
partir en 8 un joueur qui pourrait
partir en 12 que des équipes seraient
prêtes à accepter ce package
et tu vas chercher en fait si tu
m'entends 7 ou 8 pour moi tu prends le
haut du panier de ce que tu considères
comme le reste après le top 5 que si tu
te retrouves en 12 bat a déjà quatre ou
cinq joueurs que tu pourrais considérer
comme des bons joueurs qui vont être
parti donc tu récupères entre guinée
reste pour moi vraiment c'est le 30 et
le 34 un petit peu comme ce qu'on avait
eu l'année dernière on avait déjà quatre
pick l'année dernière dans le top-35
pour moi tu ça va être échangé c'est pas
possible d'avoir quatre ans qui qui vont
arriver dans cet effectif se serait même
contre-productif j'ai envie de te dire
donc mais quitte à akita avoir autant de
piques faire un package 12 30 12 30 34
et va me chercher un objet griffin en
sept ou huit vain de chercher
potentiellement bénédicte mature ans et
très chaud sur lui
si vraiment estime que j'ai dû rennes
mérite d'être pillés dans le top 10 ce
dont je ne suis pas sûr va chercher du
rennes mais pour moi soit agressif fait
un package avec ses trois pics là et va
me choper un deuxième joueur top ten
josh était d'accord il faut pas de
rareté quatre roues qui je suis
complètement d'accord avec ce que dit
constant je pense que effectivement
proposer un package après faut trouver
avec qui tu parce que c'est forcément
les équipes qui choisissent au dessus de
toi
il faut voir qui va qui va mordre à
l'hameçon c'est le luxe que s'est offert
sa me presti c'est de pouvoir négocier
ce genre de choses et donc effectivement
ça serait tout à fait pertinent
d'utiliser ces ascètes pour monter dans
la draft et choisir vraiment le joueur
que tu as envie de prendre et de rocky
ça suffit effectivement je suis d'accord
avec je suis complètement d'accord avec
ça après ça devient façon c'est la
grande question autour du thunder c'est
tellement beau à quel moment tropiques
ces tropiques quoi
quel moment tu en as déjà dans d'autres
équipes qui ont déjà plein de semis
talons en train d'éclore type orlando en
choisir
ça peut
jamais utilisé cette cette métaphore
agricole lors de lors d'un passage sur
twitch les pommes pour qu'il y en ait
une qui soit grosse il faut les
éclaircir et je pense qu'avec les
prospects c'est un petit peu pareil donc
donc il faut il faut savoir renoncer à
certains joueurs
constant a tous quelque chose à ajouter
sur cette draft 2022 du thunder
normes et fait qu'on a
c'est quand même en termes de pique le
thunder n'a jamais été aussi bien loti
en termes de pics de draft quand on
connaît la qualité de drap de sam presti
et qu'il est capable de nous sortir des
joueurs intéressants avec un pic 6 alors
on se demande ce qui va être capable de
nous faire avec un pic de et 12 donc
mais beaucoup moi beaucoup de profils
que je trouve intéressant dans la dot
que j'aime un peu moins qu'on nous
attribue un peu par facilité j'ai envie
de vous dire oui mais
alors ça c'est bien le préciser
pour on a eu plein de questions dans le
chat est en fait je les ai pas prises
c'était jean est ce que vous pensez
qu'un tel sera dispo en dise on n'en
sait rien est-ce que je peux même vous
dire c'est que même les gars 2 athletic
même de espn et peut-être bas je pense
qu'ils en savent pas beaucoup plus que
nous à un mois de la draft la plus d'un
mois de la draft l'heure à laquelle on
parle
très très compliqué de parler donc
il y aura d insight des petits trucs qui
vont fuite etc mais dans l'ensemble on
n'en sait rien donc nous on préfère ne
pas vous dire johnny davis sera dispo en
12 alors que ça se trouve sacramento
l'adorent et qui va être piquant 4 donc
on va pas répondre à ces choses là et la
majorité démocrate que vous voyez soient
cédés mock draft idéal et dans ce cas là
ça a du sens de se dire ce joueur irait
bien dans tel contexte son développement
soit assez bas il faut il faut produire
du contenu donc il faut faire du pied
josh a tous quelque chose à ajouter sur
cette droite non j'ai vraiment hâte
comme constant j'ai vraiment hâte de
voir ce que va faire sam presti
effectivement je pense que vous avez
tout vu tout à fait raison de la
confiance en lui je veux dire pour
l'instant il a il a quand même un sacré
sacré tableau de chasse à la draft donc
j'ai l'impression qu'il sait bien
s'entourer qu'il est bien conseillé
qu'il sait ce qu'il veut donc je sais
pas moi je suis assez confiant
concernant le thunder et j'ai hâte de
voir ce qu'ils vont faire mal
alan oui en trente ans oui j'ai
confiance philosophiquement en 30 jours
pour toujours ciblé deux types de
profils et rim runner hyper athlétique
pas encore développé type dernière ford
robert williams
michelle robinson il y en a toujours qui
descendent parce qu'ils sont pas prêts
et wii sont pas prêts mais c'est pour ça
qu'on les prend là où le freshman qui a
déçu moi initiés et qui descend je suis
si je dois rester entre autres je crois
en tes deux profils si je suis choqué si
élevé pour l'europe et un tas réfléchi
ou pas si tu dois je acheter
c'est compliqué parce qu'il ya peu
d'européens dans cette draft les
européens diable wedge up mais je pense
que khalifa diop le sénégalais qui joue
en espagne le laisse dans les canaries
encore un ou deux ans et je l'amène dans
deux ans c'est un tronc d'arbre
vous
connaissez il fait partie aussi là ni
l'ami mené 2-6 ans potentiellement arim
runner donc c'est là qu'il faudra fêter
ce genre de jour là si donc diop l iso
zain dure année quelque chose entre les
fans n'ont qu'une partie non et puis
pour les américains
il y en a beaucoup des rimes runner
pense là donc s'ils prennent un bon
niveau plutôt qu'on va pas rester là et
prendre un pion diabaté moussa ouais
ça ils kamagaté
complètement kamagaté kamagaté arrive à
tour nba je pense français
drafté des pivots à cette place là au
lieu d'être a été trop
très bien et pas ce sera le mot de la
fin merci à tous et encore beaucoup en
live pour ceux qui viennent d'arriver
qui sont arrivés en retard etc mais
automatiquement en replay alors c'est
pas youtube seraient menés une heure 45
mg et pourtant c'est passé très vite
donc voilà on est on est très content
d'avoir pu inaugurer ces pré draft au
luxe avec toi constant et toi josh pour
parler du thunder merci à vous deux
merci beaucoup merci
et hebbadj au fait quand même un peu de
promo
il ya un prochain numéro du corps
demain matin on fait le on fait
l'analyse des finales de conférence
boston miami game 2 et on regardera un
petit peu comment ça va se profiler pour
dallas dans le game 2 face à golden
state voilà j'aurai luca jacques aubé
lit avec moi est également quentin de
dallas mavericks du conte fr dallas
mavericks voit la super super le
programme est constant chez vous aussi
art and her plein de contenus du coup en
prévision de la draft à sur les prix oui
c'est sûr non mais là c'est la période
de l'année on avait plus de taf
globalement dimanche relève sur notre
chaîne twitch personnes devraient faire
stratégie de l'intersaison ont
globalement bien là pour le coup on va
complètement dos et le rôle de sam
presti on va essayer de de dévoiler aux
gens ce qu'on ferait à la place de sam
presti et puis sinon dans tout au tout
au long des semaines à venir jusqu'à la
draft y aura des articles sur les
joueurs y aura des live je pense qu'elle
a ne va pas c'est aussi pour nous donner
son expertise sur la grave de thé ici
donc voilà l'annoncé si vous êtes fan du
thunder globalement c'est la période
vous êtes le plus le plus content parce
que vous avez le plus de taf à faire de
notre côté et en tant que simple suiveur
et fan du thunder c'est le moment où
vous pouvez être le plus heureux
et d'ici dimanche en plus ton micro ne
grésy rappelé
live sur le merci beaucoup d'avoir fait
toutes ces manifs pour qu'on puisse pour
qu'on puisse l'entendre c'était vraiment
c'était vraiment un plaisir on vous
retrouve dans le live show steagal garde
de la vaisselle et de la cuisine pour
dans deux jours puisque on parlera des
indiana pacers
on a déjà les invités de calais
effectivement un compte et faire et
aussi mais avec melvin karsenti qui est
un spécialiste nba qui sera avec nous
pour jouer le rôle qu'a joué josh
parfaitement ce soir merci on sera avec
en lieu et place d'alan pour nous livrer
ses punchlines dont ils ont il a le
secret peut-être une ou deux recettes de
cuisine aussi et puis et puis on aura le
23 les requêtes avec
toujours un représentant des fans et
rémy reverchon et le 25 nous parlerons
des pistols
avec je me rappelle l'outil est l'invité
mais nous sur
notre compte twitter
vie professionnelle
merci à tous on ferme ce live on vous
fait des bisous merci de nous avoir
écoutés de charlie chaplin